it feels right to start with a situation
in ukraine um as
the russian forces withdraw from those
areas around kyiv we are witnessing
what they've left behind civilians
found next to bicycles next to their
shopping bags we can't show the images
of many of the atrocities but i think
it's right to kind of pause and reflect
on
you know the human face of this the cost
of what people are going through this is
sofia she's 13.
she has shrapnel now in her skull
this is just one of the images that we
can bring to people
what should the uk's response to this be
it's bob barrack i understand why you
can't show the images i think
members of parliament people in
responsibility have to view those to see
to see the scale of what we're talking
about i think after
what the world saw in syria where you
know the advent of modern technology
meant we could see images directly from
atrocities that were taking place meant
we knew these kind of images were
possible yet it's still the threshold
from some of the things i saw last night
was a new level of barbarity i think
what this country has done what what
nato have done in terms of supplying
lethal aid to the ukrainians is
obviously the right thing to have done
and i think that leads to to continue
and step up as we
get to a new phase of this conflict
where the ukrainians are having some
success pushing entrenched russian
positions back but you know what what i
wanted from the chancellor in the spring
statement was almost a sort of a wartime
statement in terms of energy you know
how we were going to make sure we
weren't still as we are right now as as
the western community buying substantial
amounts of fossil fuels from russia that
we could use
emergency measures to lower our gas
demand with us energy efficiency or more
electrification or pushing that i i
didn't feel that i think we've got to
understand this is not a a short-term
position it's going to go on it's going
to continue
to prepare for that we'll talk about the
details of the energy strategy later but
just to focus purely on
ukraine and russia and you're right to
say that we're still spending an awful
lot of money on oil and gas in europe in
particular you know since the start of
the war i think the eu has spent 18
billion euros on russian oil and gas i
mean any sanctions going to have an
impact at all when russia is still
effectively being banked by europe well
they will have an effect and they are
having an effect because the level of
sanctions are very significant certainly
in terms of how the russians the russian
ruble has effectively recovered
we've tried to isolate as the world
community russia from the from the
global economy whilst at the same time
having that dependency now in terms of
oil
the danger is you just go from one
autocratic authoritarian regime to
another so that's not a long-term
solution
russian gas i think there's a bit of
complacency in the uk because
russian gaffe in the main goes to
central europe but of course because of
that countries like norway then supply
the uk so we've got to understand that
what is required is not anything which
increases our dependency long term on
fossil fuels but gets us off that
dependency and that is why there's going
to be this
further sprint on renewables there are
things we've got a good story in this
country and offshore wind but on things
like onshore wind a bad story where
we've had effectively a ban in place so
there are other things that can be done
but it's not it can't be going from one
country to another deciding just who's
the most unpalatable this month this
year it's got to be that longer term
conversion to electrification to further
renewables to further nuclear because
that's the only way forward we'll talk
about that a little bit more later the
government's also promised a safe haven
for ukrainian refugees in the uk are
they delivering on that
well i think the rhetoric
after the initial period
has been
where it needs to be and the delivery of
that is a further question i think
there's been a huge response from the
british people around this in terms of
people signing up for the halls for
ukrainian scheme
the worry is how how is that feeding
through on the ground the bureaucracy
that's required behind that making sure
people are coming through
i don't think because we've seen in the
past few years some horrible situations
would have led to significant
humanitarian flaws i almost think we're
struggling to understand the sheer scale
of this i mean the figures of people in
poland and romania alone
these are levels of movements of people
in europe that we just haven't seen for
decades and i think when you see what
other countries are coping with and
doing it's hard to say that as of yet we
have met the scale of that challenge so
i hope the government recognises that
and is willing to do more the other
thing we can of course do is to provide
more weaponry you said earlier that you
think that should be stepped up
what exactly do you mean by step top
well the first phase of this conflict
has seen
a tremendous response from the ukrainian
armed forces using essentially western
train tactics light units with anti-tank
weaponry which has stopped the advance
of russian units but obviously this is
now a different phase as they retreat
and we're obviously seeing unfortunately
atrocities occur as those forces leave
so that might require a different level
even if russia would see that as an
escalation i think russia's
position in terms of what they have
already done and what they are doing it
would be a little bit rich of them to
claim escalation on the part or over the
civilized countries i think we've got to
listen very carefully to what ukrainians
are telling us about the equipment they
need there's a different balance there
maybe in terms of air defense units and
heavier artillery compared to the
lighter units that have had such
brilliant success and a brilliant
performance by the ukrainians so far but
we've got it we've got to listen to that
and respond to that because frankly i
think the sanctions have had a
significant effect on russia's ability
to resupply and keep the occupation
forces in place
but what we are seeing in terms of them
leaving you this is not
i'm afraid it's not the end of the
conflict it's not a peaceful position
we're returning to we've got to
acknowledge that okay well let's uh talk
now about the energy strategy shall we
you mentioned a bit earlier in the
interview um
next week we're expecting the prime
minister to unveil it it feels as if the
briefing
today is all about nuclear with the
business secretary saying up to seven
new nuclear plants but of course
that's not going to help families with
their bills now is it and that's going
to take 13 to 17 years to for that
energy to come into the stream does
labor support the broad direction of
where the government's moving well we do
support and more nuclear in the system
alongside that further development of
renewables i think the dangers you say
is that whilst that's for the long term
and frankly the the individual
commissioning decisions on nuclear
reactors all depend on the price you can
achieve and that relates very much to
the financing of the media at the right
price to the right thing to do they can
be very expensive if you haven't been
able to get the right deal and the right
private sector partners to do that i
think none of that
should be used as a small screen to get
away from the real issue which is right
now the cost of living is absolutely
extreme energy bills are a huge part of
that the government hasn't done enough
there's no way they can say they've done
enough the scheme they put forward i
think where the chance is offering to
lend us our own money and pay it back
over five years is completely
unrealistic and doesn't meet the scale
of the challenge what we want to do of
course is that windfall taxes offer
people real support 600 pounds for a
third of households off their energy
bills that's the scale of what is
required and whatever the long-term
energy strategy the government unveil it
can't get away from the fact that
they've got to take some action now to
help people i mean something that could
have an impact in the short term is
looking at the supply of oil and gas as
well isn't it and was it the right
decision by the north sea transition
agency to look at this two year
extension of the cambodia's oil fields
license well
domestic gas and oil from the north sea
is a about half our domestic supply at
the minute and that should continue when
no one questions that strategy the
longer term extraction picture for all
fossil fuels around the world has to be
of course governed by you say that but
at the same time labour has previously
opposed the development of
the cambodia oil field and you're
talking about windfall tax in the north
sea as well you know if you were looking
at this you might think that actually
labour isn't that happy about the idea
of what's being calling it it's got to
be governed by the small and short it's
going to be governed by the committee on
climate change there's no point in the
country having is that right does it is
that is that what you think the priority
should be achieving net zero opposed to
bringing bills there's no point this
country having
a ambitious climate strategy if we're
not going to stick to it and of course
even if people face
huge
huge
like difficulties with paying their
bills even if people are having to turn
off their health let's be clear more
domestic supply is about the security of
that supply it's not about the price the
price is set by the global market price
for that so even if we for instance
wanted to go down the route of
extracting a fundamentally larger amount
of oil and gas from the uk that wouldn't
affect the price the only way to affect
the price is to focus on energy
efficiency so people are using less is
to switch to uh domestic cheaper
electrification of heating so it's very
important people understand that point
there is a one thing that's different
about the situation now because of what
russia has done is there's an argument
about substitution of supplies that
would have perhaps come from russia
coming from other parts of the world so
when i say the committee on climate
change has to look at that picture in
the round that is exactly what they will
do but anyone who thinks
bills or supply in the long term can be
sold by more dependents on fossil fuels
that is a mistake you've got to look at
the alternative which is renewables and
nuclear i've got two very short
questions to squeeze in before we have
to let you go firstly david warburton
has had the conservative whip withdrawn
after allegations made in sunday times
now without going into the details
of the case you know he says he's heard
nothing from the
independent complaints and grievance
scheme do you have concerns about the
culture in westminster
well i've read the story and that's all
i know about this particular thing i i
think the vast majority of members of
parliament
work very hard for their constituents
whatever their party affiliation you
know certainly as a front venture for
most of my time in parliament i've been
you know in opposition it's quite
quite a lot of work to make sure you're
matching the capacity the government has
in the civil service i think there are
in any uh sector i've worked in whether
that's the legal sector of politics i
think there are people who sometimes
you know aren't balancing the
responsibilities and the burdens on them
in the right way and they sometimes you
know that gets them into trouble and
behavior they shouldn't do but i don't
think politics is any different in my
experience to other high pressured
sectors in relation to how people behave
okay and finally just summarize will you
um the tax policy that you want to try
and enhance today well the cost of
living is extreme the government isn't
doing enough and people will be better
off under labour so that's because we
wouldn't have proceeded with the
national insurance rise it's because we
would have done that windfall tax to
help people with their energy bills it's
because on business rates which is a
huge expense for business we would have
frozen the valuations we would have
increased the threshold at which
businesses paid business rates so the
average pub or hairdresser on top of
what the government have done would be
around two to three thousand pounds
better off so we do real help for people
now and that's what would make a
difference okay that's the labour pitch
then uh we'll get the government pitch
uh in just a few moments uh time but
thank you for being on the programme
today thank you